from groups like The rspca and others
which is that one they claim that breed
doesn't matter and two if it did matter
which we can see from statistics
cross-culturally it does I mean if it
does you can't do anything about it
Beyond with that is that there are uh at
least two different routes which seem to
be quite effective we've banned Pitbull
types actually not just a Pitbull breed
we banned Pitbull types since 1991.
because the government hasn't updated
the guidance on what defines a pit bull
and a pit bull types of all the crosses
and for instance American Bully excels
and American bullies probably fall under
this as well really
um the guidance if it was updated could
reflect this and these dogs just simply
wouldn't have been able to be imported
into the country originally the fact
that government hasn't updated the
guidance essentially created a loophole
where these dolls could then be imported
now we see the effects and in fact we
can see how good and how effective
Banning uh Pitbull types has been in
that the moment we get back Pit Bull
type dog our attacks Skyrocket